any Fault in the earth at depth is under
stress it's under stress from the weight
of the rocks above it and it's also
under stress from tectonic stresses in
the crust when we're fracking we're
injecting pressurized fluid underground
we're doing this in order to actually
make cracks in the rock of interest in
order to get the gas out however during
your fracking operation if you intersect
a pre-existing fault that pressurized
fluid can find that fault and unpin it
just a little bit and allow it
earthquake to occur once we've collected
all the fracking fluid at the surface it
needs to be disposed in a more permanent
way we inject fluids underground and if
it intersects a fault it could cause an
earthquake at that point
as a recent study that just came out in
Ohio that showed a fault that was
intersected near a fracking well only
that earthquakes along and only began
when the fracking operation started
intersecting the fault so they they have
regular fracking operations going on and
no earthquakes as they move closer to
the Fault in space which they didn't
know existed
the earthquakes turned on
and the Midwest and the eastern United
States a lot of the faults are very
ancient and we don't know where all of
them are and there isn't a lot of
surface expression so we need to be very
careful and looking for faults before
fracking operations begin and that would
be a good way to reduce our risk of
causing an earthquake